alright okay we're live another hangout
I just came off a hang on here we are
another one uh this is a cool one so one
of my loyal YouTube subscribers Brandon
as a teenage entrepreneur and he wanted
to ask you some questions and I thought
hey why don't we do a google hangout and
chat about it so that other people who
are in the same situation could learn
from it his webcams having some issues
so you're going to see my face and then
black screen when Brandon comes on and
there's also a spot to ask questions if
you guys wanted to chat and we'll try to
get to those as I come up so Brandon
welcome hey was so hey man I'm good
thank you how are you I'm great good so
what's up how can I help um so I think
for me my biggest fear being a teenager
and wanting to go into entrepreneurship
is not knowing what my passion is and
what will drive me throughout my life so
I know you've been you've had quite a
few businesses yeah I've heard you speak
about within your videos what sort of
advice would you give to you know a
teenager to start their journey uh if
you don't know what your passion is my
best advice is to start exploring the
worst thing you can do especially as a
teenager is is get locked into one thing
and then slowly hate it and hate it and
hate it more and more and more right the
longer you're on that path the harder it
is to get off the wheel right like if
you're 40 and you have two kids and a
wife and you know you always wanted to
try something it becomes a lot harder
because now you've got all these other
responsibilities where now is a good
time to go and try different things and
see what you fall in love with and and
often it's not the one that makes the
most sense um this is why I say you need
to listen to your heart and not your
head because if you just kind of made a
list of the things you're good at and
try to logically pick something it's
usually not the thing that's best for
you you just need to go out and explore
and try different things until you fall
in love with something that's often
gonna be the best opportunity right and
what would you say
you say go and find your passion what's
the best way for some like a teenager to
you know not starting up with a lot of
money how would you sell can build
myself up to search for my passion um so
give you an example okay I'll give you
three rock climbing snowboarding and
salsa dancing okay um I like doing
things once and that's I think it's a
good mindset at least its work for me if
somebody invites you to do something do
it once try right you want to be open to
new experiences and trying new things
and you may not ever go back and do it
again but at least you tried it uh
rock-climbing i hate i suck at it I
don't like the thing being in my crotch
I'm afraid of heights I don't like it so
like I'm not going back rock climbing
snowboarding I went once with my wife
and I loved it and I fell in love with
it I became obsessed with it I got all
the gear immediately the next season
opened up and I went every day to the
snowboarding hill I would push meetings
I find reasons to go out on the
snowboarding hill and and that like you
want to follow that flow if you get
obsessed with something you want to dive
into it more because there's
opportunities there right if my if I
knew that snowboarding would be my big
passion I could build tons of different
businesses around it if it's making
snowboards if it's teaching snowboarding
but it's doing a YouTube channel in
snowboarding it would selling
accessories of snowboard like this tons
of businesses you can start around that
passion Boudica I was the next year I
didn't love it as much like i exhausted
my passion for it and i still go a
couple times a year but it's not a
burning thing that I love doing salsa
dancing I picked up ten years ago or so
and I fell in love with it too and I'm
still doing it so I love it and and and
on paper it looks it looks terrible
because I'm tall which makes it hard for
me dancing I take big steps no I don't I
don't know spanish I don't her send the
music I'd never done dancing before and
learning as an adult is a lot harder
than as a child if you grow up with it
so all these reasons why I wouldn't work
for me as a business but i loved it i
fell in love with
I became an investor in the maybe north
america's largest salsa dancing company
teach five six thousand students here
how to do it I'm still dancing 20 hours
a week so the key is to try things right
like I walked into a salsa class just
out of something fun to do and it became
a passion of mine and it became a huge
business opportunity for me in speaking
entrepreneurs like what I do now just
came out of a random opportunity the
ymca asked me to come and speak to their
group of entrepreneurs after I'd sold my
business I was 22 when i sold my first
business um and they asked him to come
and speak is it sure I'll come and speak
and share my knowledge why not and I
spent so much time preparing making the
perfect powerpoint i wanted to get all
my knowledge out really helped them and
you know i show up on the day and it was
a free event and only three people
showed up and that was like my heart
stopped right like i spent all this time
working and it's a free event and only
three people show up are you kidding me
uh but you know the show must go on
those 20 people came so I'm gonna I'm
gonna do my presentation at least three
people and it was awesome you know those
three people walked away change people
they had new motivation ideas help grow
their business and I felt so fulfilled
and happy to do this one free thing that
I thought I don't know how I'm ever
gonna make money at it because if you
look at it on paper if you can't get
more than three people to show up for a
free thing how are you ever going to
make money at this or I didn't make any
sense but I loved it so much that I knew
I had to find a way to keep going even
if either do something else i would keep
doing this because i loved it so much
and that became everything that you see
now with the youtube channel on the
website and the consultant i do all of
that came out of that one random thing
that I just said yes to so if you don't
know what you want to do that's cool
like it's great to know that you don't
know because that gives you options and
and the answer isn't listen to your
parents who tell you to go be an
accountant or you know go take these
classes because that's the safe smart
thing
do it's exploring what you find
interesting until you find something
that you fall in love with yeah and I
think that's a great point um I think
it's also to do with when you start off
you know at a young age really I wanted
to start your own business how would you
what would you say is the best way to
network with people to find people who
are who can relate to you and also help
build your business with you I would try
to find people who have the same passion
that I have but have different skill
sets so right ah you know whatever
you're interested in say you're
interested in soccer and you want to
build a business around soccer I try to
hang out with people who also loved
soccer because that's going to be the
that's the binding glue right you need
everybody at my business who works for
me you've got 14 people on my team they
all love helping entrepreneurs I like
why are we doing this right because I
love helping entrepreneurs yeah
everybody on my team loves helping
entrepreneurs if you don't love
entrepreneurs you're not gonna fit in
right you can be the greatest programmer
you know the greatest sales person
whatever you're not going to be a fit
with me because you don't love
entrepreneur so at the same time
everybody does different things you know
the cameraman because I can't I'm not
great at shooting myself I got a video
editor because I don't want to do that
work either I got a researcher because I
don't want to do that work either so you
know whether you're finding partners for
your business or finding people to work
for you ah the key thing is that you
have something that binds you all
together you have a joint shared passion
but you have different skill sets
because you don't need two of you I
don't need to Evans I need people who
can support me to help me accomplish my
goals right and i think also with trying
to find a mentor as well you know trying
to get someone who's willing to take
their time out to help you where they
have already succeeded yeah so uh two
things there one is ask right like do
your research and ask a lot of people
don't ask for help they try to do it
themselves and you can't do it yourself
you need help right uh why are we doing
this you asked right yeah here we are
answer questions up
I'd also say don't ask somebody to be
your mentor because I mentors a
relationship you know it's like walking
up to some random girl in the streets in
hey you want to be my girlfriend right
there's a commitment level which is
scary and nobody's going to commit to
that nobody say yes I'll be your mentor
just from like a cold email or youtube
common or whatever so you make it simply
make it easy you say I'd like to ask you
a couple questions do you mind if we go
for coffee or do a google hangout or
whatever it is a phone call and a lot of
you'll find a lot of successful people
are willing to open their doors if they
feel like one you've got energy and two
you're going to actually act on the
information like there's nothing worse
or a mentor point of view to see you
give great advice as somebody and then
they don't do it and they keep holding
themselves back and they'll take your
advice and then like you don't want to
continue that relationship so it's
reaching out and having energy and not
asking for too much just asking for a
quick call and write if you do your work
of finding you know like you reached out
to me you like something on what I'm
doing hoping to get some advice and so I
said yes and here we I rights is it can
be that simple I just have to go and ask
and I think also you know starting out
um how do you balance it to where you
have a good living but you're still
trying up new things with the money that
you have ah well you know when you're
starting out you don't have money for
the most people i don't know if you've
got something for your family or
whatever but um or job and it's okay i'm
from the school that you don't have to
dive all in on the business it's okay to
have a part-time job and be in school
and try to start your business so you
have some income stream coming in so you
can spend the time on your business a
lot of people they go the opposite they
quit you know they have a job or they
quit school they quit their job and they
go all in on their business and then
they find out it takes way longer than
they thought it would and they run out
of money and they have to go back to
school go back to get their job or
whatever so I find
doesn't work because it takes longer you
think it will and you run out of savings
really quickly so the better way to do
it is on the side part time right so if
you're you have a job that gives you
some money that's great ideally is a job
that doesn't just give you money but
teaches you how to be a better
entrepreneur so if you wanted to you
know open up your own shoe store then go
work at a shoe store to start right like
learn the ropes make the connections
make the mistakes while getting paid
like you're getting paid to learn how
this industry works don't see it as a
job see it as an education that you're
getting paid to do um so don't just go
job for money and look ideally I look
for companies that are small you know 10
employees or less and then try to get as
close to the entrepreneur founder as
possible to learn from them to gain
experience take on more projects then
you're given like you're hired to do
this don't just do that do anything
anything that they want right learn and
then you'll use that experience to then
when you go launch your own company
it'll make sure your you know you make
less mistakes you make money more
quickly and you can also tell if it's
the right business for you like if you
have an idea to start a shoe company and
you go work at a shoe company you may
not want to start a shoe company anymore
right like you realize that that's not
what I want to do and that just saved
you a ton a headache and ass on money
going down the wrong path yeah I think
that's a great point and also going back
to starting off with no contacts yeah
what would you say is the best way to
build a great team that's it that's a
great question uh when I started you
know I didn't want to use my parents or
I don't want to use their help I don't
know I hide it in my head like I got to
do this myself my parents had some
connections I probably would have helped
me but I'm like I got to do this on my
own don't wanna have my parents help me
uh which was that also a problem because
I didn't know anybody yeah it's great to
have that mindset but then like well I
know zero you know none of my friends
were doing anything like this so how am
I going to get going and my first real
business was in University and to fellow
university students had a software
company that wasn't doing so well and I
join
to help them and look okay well with the
three of us are going but we need we
need more you know we got to build this
thing up and I went to go talk to my
banker and like I thought foolishly
bankers are supposed to help small
business right that's what they're here
for the help us and front that's not
what they're there for which I
discovered but like I literally new 0 I
knew nobody so I went to go talk to my
Baker and he's like well do you need a
loan like not i don't know i don't know
if i need a loan you know i don't know
what i'm doing i need help is it well
you know okay I can't give you money
based on that and he took I feel if he
took pity on me or he just saw my energy
and enthusiasm um he made an
introduction to me so he introduced me
to somebody who would work with some of
his banker clients and that guy was
ended up being a total douchebag but he
connected us to somebody else and he
connected us to somebody else and that
that third guy became really strong
mentors name was John he can really
strong mentor for us to help us grow
he'd done this a number of times and his
advice I was 19 at the time so like I
knew only what was in my textbooks which
they don't really teach about
entrepreneurship a lot in schools and
that really helped me but it's just
started to talk to people right like if
your specific if you know uh here's what
I'm trying to learn here's what I'm
trying to understand uh and you put that
on people's radar then they'll think
about ways that they can help you right
so you can reach out yourself like you
did to me like we're doing this right
now but there's also like what are you
trying to build right I'm trying to
build a gaming channel right so now
that's on my radar right I get they go
who do I know in gaming that may be able
to help right up right so it's just
starting to ask and get the word and
it's often not the person that that is
right in front of you like it may not be
if you're telling your friends or your
friends family whatever or you go to a
meetup and you're talking about it's
often not that person it's just somebody
they know and by you being clear but
what you're looking for that puts it on
their radar and and they often know
somewhere that can connect you so it's
like a friend of a friend that ends up
being the person to help
oops right and i think when i first
started this channel I thought that
making videos you know gaming videos was
my passion but now I've sort of i'm not
sure i'm on that you know trying to
balance out what I think my passion is
and what I want to do yeah it's super
common and you know congrats for having
the thought process because a lot of
people they start on that one path and
then they're too afraid to learn my
business is always a reflection of what
I'm interested in and and how I'll build
it up is I try a lot of stuff I'll try a
lot of different projects something
comes into my hand I never try it out
and most of them don't go anywhere and
that's okay and then the ones that do I
build it up to the point where either i
love it and i keep doing it or lose it
and then can I hire somebody to then
take that over for me or it's not big
enough yet then I drop it I move on to
something else and that takes a lot of
guts and courage because you may not
even know what you want to do next right
you just know it's not this anymore so
you look at the youtube channel since
you watch the videos i started with just
my regular camera like I didn't go out
and buy anything think that's the
mistake a lot of people make is they go
and they buy stuff for their company I
could have bought the tripod on the gear
and the lights and the microphone and
the camera and all that and spent
thousands of dollars done you know three
months worth of videos and then felt
like I you know I know I don't think
this is for me meanwhile i'm stuck with
thousands of dollars worth of gear right
uh so i started with nothing like just
with my camera that i had i could have
used my laptop or something right just
really ghetto and then as I that was one
of the things that I fell in love with
like I love making the YouTube videos
and I keep doing it and it's one of my
passion so I've slowly invested into
more gear and two more team but there's
plenty of other things that I'll start
and try and I don't love and then I move
on to something else so you know if you
started a gaming channel because you
know you like the game and it was great
and you wanted to test yourself and now
you're into it like ah you know I'm not
feeling any more right if you're not
making enough money the
I or someone to take it over for you
then stop it and go do something else
something that is excited for you that's
it's a tough decision like it takes guts
to do it but you'll never create
something great if you're not really
excited by it right you're just
maintaining it yeah it's never going to
be something amazing you're never going
to be really fulfilled you're never
going to make a lot of money it won't be
fantastic if you are not pouring your
love into it and maybe when you started
that you're raising I love this and
learning here we go and then it's like
my snowboarding thing my passion fizzled
that happens right and then move on to
something else what would you say the
best time period to try new things
because it you know if you do if you try
skiing out right for like one time and
you don't think that you like it but if
you'd stuck with it it turns out to be
your passion what sort of time period
would you say to try new things up is ah
that's an interesting question um I end
to listen to my gut as much as I can and
I guess the more things you try the more
your intuition will will teach you what
you like and what you don't but I
haven't found very many things i love i
can think of anything where I hated it
at the start and then turn out to love
in it right um you know you could you
can hate something that may be like it a
little bit more by removing some of the
things I hated about it but I tend to
look for things that I love at the start
even if it's like like snowboarding I
got up I fell I fell that first day
maybe a hundred times I fell my knees
are bleeding my ass is on fire like I
was sucking hard I couldn't get up going
down a tiny hill but I loved it for some
reason right like I gotta keep doing
this and so that's the difference like
any new thing that you take on you will
suck at the start you want to pick up a
new game you're gonna suck out you want
to pick up a new language you're going
to suck out you want to start in the
business and go to suck em anything you
start you are not great at the start of
it but if you see those as big
negatives like ah you know I'm not good
at it so I'm going to give up on it then
you probably shouldn't do in the first
place but if you see those as
opportunities like uh you know ok I suck
but I can get better if I practice and I
work on and I'm excited to learn more
salsa I sucked that at the start
speaking I sucked at at the start but I
loved it right and so I wanted to just
keep going and doing it it's like if you
walk away from trying something new
thinking about like ah if I had done
this and there's something like tweaked
it and change my strategy a little bit
or tried that like I went home thinking
about it I wake up the next day thinking
about it that's when you know you found
something that's worth investing more
time into right and I think also with
going back to building a great team as
well yeah I think finding contacts for
me I just feel like I'm kind of
struggling with it trying to find the
right people I'm not going to find them
you know really fast but yeah I got I
just feel kind of confused and what I
should try out first with the money that
I have yeah I mean ah the easiest thing
is to figure out what it is that you
stand for so first of all like what if
what is what is your goal like what are
you trying to accomplish right what is
the big thing that you want to do if you
don't know what you want to do that's
hard to bring on a team right right like
there's no clear vision so who am i
bringing on with me and so like the team
is secondary like you got to figure out
where you're going first before you can
bring your team um and then too like
what's what's the really important value
to you like who are you as a person that
you bring to your business you bring to
your your life you bring to your
relationships so I'm all about believe
you got to figure out what what you're
all about when then you understand those
two things what you stand for is a
person and what mission you're on then
it's a lot easier to bring on people and
find them and find them quickly now I
found a lot of my most recent hires
super quick without even ever meeting
them sometimes just online right but
it's really clear if I'm talking about
believe in my job posting and talking
about helping entrepreneur
and I like who's that for the first
paragraph uh people will love it or the
like a bully was so stupid believe what
the heck man you know like awesome like
we would never work well together that
is amazing right don't even apply to my
job it's awesome right um if we talk
about helping entrepreneurs some people
think well I don't care who I help I
just want to design software or whatever
right like so when you're using that
stuff out then you eliminate all the
people who won't be good fits for you
and you attract a smaller group but
people who are way more exciting right
you'll see people were like wow finally
right this is so amazing my video editor
I wanted to have a belief tattoo on her
arm she didn't do it but before she ever
met me and so she was already you know
aligned with it and like the idea of
helping entrepreneurs and so we were
just a natural fit and I hired her and
haven't looked back um and it keeps
people to write like if you do a good
job in the selection of the start it
keeps them on board but it's it's much
more about you and your process and it
is about that like if you're unclear but
where you're going and who you are and
you have a generic job posting you're
going to get generic people who suck
right like you're going to attract the
wrong people always so you got to get
clear on that if you don't know that's
cool right like figure that out and then
you go and bring on a team right and
also like you said with generic people
you know sort of mediocrity and stuff
like that when would you say is the best
time to go out and start a business full
time I know you say start at part time
to see how it goes yeah but when should
someone decide when they should quit
their job and go straight into the
business whatever it is enough moneys
for yourself and that doesn't mean like
life of luxury like you're not out
buying Ferraris and stuff just support
yourself right like I can make enough
money to live my life and I don't know
if you're living with your parents or
somewhere else or whatever you have
monthly expenses your monthly bill is X
right like bare minimum i can pay my
cell phone i can go to like one dinner
month or whatever you know uh bare
minimum when you can make that amount
working part time then you know that hey
if I go full time I'll make more right
that's that's your first step like I
would encourage you to start part-time
learn from somebody who can teach you
the ropes of an industry and then start
your business on the side and when
you're making enough to pay your bills
and support yourself then jump in full
time quit your job you know school I
don't know if you want to go down that
road or not but at least quit your job
and and focus on on your business full
time because you're going to have enough
money to get by right and I think really
the year the last question is are you
working on the top 10 success rules from
Lord Sugar ah let me see these on my
list I'm seeing the British accent there
um Lord Sugar so it's funny all of the
all of the people yeah I do Ian fairly
asked asked me for it so it's coming i
have about i don't know i want to say a
hundred people now in the queue all from
request so the xpress oh and the top 10
are all from requests I'm picked anybody
I think I picked I did the first one who
is the first one somebody asked me to do
like a collection on or whatever so like
even that one I haven't picked any of
them and so I just try to see like
what's next in the line up so he's
coming slowly well guess um was good
good to get that extra little push yeah
there's some questions coming in that we
can answer here on the stream so I'm
going to hear fourteen-year-old
freelancer I'm dealing with some
allergies here it's a little crazy um my
parents tell me to go to school stop
doing it and go to high school I want to
do entrepreneur stuff on my parents
don't want me to do that how do i get
rid of it uh just a metaphor that the
school and I danced around it um you
know I don't want to be the guy says
quit school and go do your business um I
think it's all it's a mean as a
sick backup plan in case your company
doesn't work out honestly the most help
that I got out of my university was just
the connections I remember being in a
fourth-year class at university of
toronto which is you know the most well
recognized university in canada and
there was a small business class there
and i took it in and it was so basic you
know I was already way beyond that in
what I was already doing for my business
and felt like I was wasting my time
there but i still graduated and finish
my degree and i didn't go beyond
bachelors um you're talking when i went
to high school you know you got to do
what you feel is right the the example
that i use is michael dell where his
parents wanted him to be doctors and he
didn't want to be a doctor he wanted to
start his computer company dell and he
started it out of his university dorm
room and he made an agreement with his
parents to say that i want to try this
this is my passion i'm going to take a
summer i'm not going to work on the
summer and i'm gonna do my business and
if it doesn't work out then i'm going to
go back to school if it does work out
and I'm going to leave school and keep
doing my business and that was a deal
that he made and his parents said yes
and obviously it worked out and he never
went back to school and I think he's
happy there's an entrepreneur not a
doctor worth many billions of dollars um
doesn't this arrows work out like that
and and you know you want to have a
happy relationship with your parents as
much as possible I know it can be hard
if they're not supporting you and your
dreams what you want to do you know it's
understanding that this is the balance
right like most of the times because
they love you and they want to support
you and the way they think they're
supporting you is telling you to do the
safe thing because that's what they did
right you know at the same time though
your environment holds you where you are
and as much of the advice that you
getting is out of love if the people who
you're listening to haven't done what
you want to do then they are not really
fit to advise you right like if your
school counselor is telling you to do
this and you want to be an entrepreneur
they've never been an entrepreneur and
they can
really give you the advice that you need
to get to where you want to go um so
dancing around the question still I
would say try to do something similar to
del where you are starting your business
part-time you can manage part-time while
still going to school and try to build
it into something build into something
that you can show them is working and is
making you money and prove it to
yourself like prove to yourself that you
can turn your ideas into a business and
and then if you make a lot of money from
it you can support yourself make that
call if you want to stay in school or
not right um what else I know my
business can work and I would quit
school if I could but my parents are
stopping me yeah so like there I would
say my business can work like show that
it can work like you could do it part
time show that it can work prove it to
yourself prove with your parents booth
everybody that it can work you don't
need to you don't need to quit that's a
school or a job you don't need to quit
to start it right you you have time
every day to pour into your business and
not play league of legends or clash of
clans or watch Game of Thrones and all
that stuff like put that into your
business and see if you could take it
off prove it to yourself you can make
money what are you what are you doing uh
Brandon are you are you in school I
assuming you're in school right 17 yeah
so in the UK on 17 obviously there's a
thing called an apprenticeship ok so
it's Conway what you spoke about I'm in
a small business with about 10 employees
it's a recruitment agency and I
basically learn on the job while I have
like online work to do which gets me
basically an a level which is like a
degree and then I also have the
experience so that they've only just
been really introduced back into the UK
but yet it's basically a job drive it um
but on part time I've started computer
cleaning I've got I've gone round with
with lawyers put them into people's you
know post boxes and just waiting for
responses I mean I've only just started
it
sure and so the difference there is fig
thinking about you know how are you
doing something just trying to make
money or doing something because you're
excited by are you excited about
computer cleaning or not well then I
with it if you are but um if you're just
letting the company i think the majority
of the reason is for the money right now
just to raise some money so that i can
go into something that I really love
like when I trailer backing what do you
love um I'm not sure right now right so
i could turn anything into a business
just yet i think i need some more well
that's different like so that's
different than what do you love like how
do i turn into businesses after but what
is it that you love and if you don't
know that's cool that's a good arm
estate normal oh i'd say i love video
games but i'm not sure how i turn that
into you know like you said a business
later on there's tons of ways right like
you can either be a gamer yourself and
you're you're entering into competitions
and your winning prize money or if it
what game do you play clash of clans is
that your game yeah okay um i don't know
if there's tournaments or whatever on
clash your clients i'm in the league of
legends um anybody who's wants to do a
duo queue with me a link a legend I'm
not that great a player but I have fun
with it you can carry me the victory um
yeah on all the games is you know
there's the top players and there's you
can make money doing that you can make
money streaming right you can run any
streaming you can get sponsors the more
attention you have the more money and
opportunities that you have so you were
trying to like your channel was about
clash of clans tips and information
right right yeah but that seemed that so
you love computer games you love classic
lines but you don't love what you're
doing on your YouTube channel that's
cool like it's a good experiment what
was wrong with it like maybe you didn't
like the added a maybe didn't like the
recording like what did what don't you
like about your channel but you love
above clash your clients I think it will
see editon more than anything else
I just didn't think that the sort of
editing that people put into their
videos and our days on YouTube that I
couldn't perform that well because I
just don't have much experience I don't
really enjoy editing videos right well
so that's the difference the experience
is the matter because you can learn
quickly if you're passionate about it
you don't the interest in it there's
something else and so so now it's
figuring out well until I can get an
editor how do I build this up if you
still enjoy doing the videos how do I
build it up without an editor so for
example could you do coaching could you
coach somebody know how to do clash of
clans and get better at it it's an
example do you know anything about
league of legends yeah I've tried it out
yeah okay so this is there's a character
named heimerdinger I don't know if you
know him or not who I'm trying to learn
and get better at and there's not a lot
of great videos and tutorials on
heimerdinger and there's one guy out of
the UK called rezone gaming or resume
game something like that who has great
videos on how to play heimerdinger and
and most of the mart super polished
video some of them are but it's a lot of
which is his gameplay like he's playing
the game and he's commentating on it
he's saying why he's doing this and
talking about strategy while he's
playing it right well the watch is like
40 minute videos I'll sit there watching
them and then it made me reach out to
him and say hey I'm trying to learn how
to play heimerdinger better do you do
coaching and he said yes I do and it is
in the UK it's 25 pounds an hour to do a
coaching session with him well which in
the US is like I don't know 40 bucks
yeah 35 bucks an hour something like
that um and I'm gonna do it right like
this is how crazy it is i'm going to pay
to learn how to play hi everything or
better from this guy in the UK and so
like this opportunities but he's
providing great value doing what he
loves talking about league of legends
and and you could do something similar
you could do coaching calls with people
and record them and put them up in a
showcases how how good you are at clash
of clans or you find a different angle
just eliminate the like right now you're
saying well I don't have an editor and
so I can't move forward
my goal but i still love clash of clans
the better response would be looking
well I can't do it this way how do I go
around and do something else right
they'll be within the same niche right
if you love it keep going and doing it
um there's money to be made right I'm
paying this guy and you'll make more
money like 25 pounds an hour maybe
you're not there yet but you work up
you'll make more money doing that then
doing like how much can you make selling
a computer cleaning service per hour I
mean yeah that's the same that only 25
pounds right an hour when you're either
be coaching clash of clans or cleaning
out computers yeah with the computers
Yeah right and this guy that I'm I'm
working with is not a big name dude he's
not he's not a celebrity right he just
he's good at one character heimerdinger
that's when I won't get better and so
I'm going to work with him if you want
to do coaching with people who are way
better you know you're looking at double
triple quadruple ten times that amount
so it just depends on how you know how
good a coach you are how good a player
you are and that comes from your passion
right like there's no way you can get to
that level if you don't love the game
that you're playing and invest time and
applying it and to learning and to want
to teach other people right I don't
think as well I think like you said it
is just all about exploring and that's I
think that's what i need to do really to
start it's definitely a good start man
you always start with exploring there's
more questions coming in roanoke i'm
curling entrepreneurs student working
full-time job ambitious help to be a
full-time entre prefer graduating any
tips on managing time successfully uh
you know school to school you have your
assignments but when you're graduating i
would do the same strategy we're talking
about like keep your job and in start
part-time or try to transition that like
part time job and go more hours on your
business until you what what were your
making money the managing time um the
two thoughts i have on that are one
you want to make sure that your time is
being spent wisely which is why i said
when you're taking a job you're learning
right it's not just money you're
learning right so that that's a good use
of time a bad use of time is walking
dogs for 25 pounds an hour because you
hate walking dogs but you're just trying
to make some money like that's not a
great use of time you can make that same
amount of money doing something that you
love and helps improve you so make sure
the time you're spending is being used
on something where you're learning and
the second part of that is every day do
something on your business no excuses
it's easy to come up with excuses right
it's easy to say oh you know I slept
only three hours outside i'm really
tired or you know big family crisis
happening like you can always find a
reason for not doing something half an
hour at least every single day ideally
more but at least half an hour every
single day on the business you make the
time for the things that are important
to you another one Adam love your
streams and currently learning copyright
answer my own e-commerce tyrant but some
days I almost want to give up that's
super common like this like this big lie
and entrepreneurship that you're always
excited about your business and I think
it's because we invest so much into it
that we always you go out and you talk
to people but your what you're doing
it's always the good stuff right like I
just got x new subscribers I just got
this big new client where every
entrepreneur thinks about quitting at
some point multiple times and then the
key thing goes figuring out like do you
still actually love this used to have a
passion are you investing more time into
figuring things out and you're still
genuinely excited with what you're doing
or it's a time to move on and do
something else uh what keeps you going
to where you want to go I don't know man
I just love helping entrepreneurs like
why do you keep breathing you know you
have to uh if I stopped loving
entrepreneurs like this is this business
than going for 12 years almost um if I
got tired of it like I would
snowboarding then i would go do
something else but as of now i still
love it i wake up excited by it i'm
happy to
to your questions and happy to answer
Brandon's questions um how do you
explain love I don't know what keeps me
going is love so you gotta find what you
love yeah uh and a whole bunch of these
things coming in tweezers come with
excuses it's right momona I really sat
down with my exams and didn't perform
too well it made me reevaluate my
decision about further education I know
that I have good leadership skills and I
want to follow entrepreneurship but I
know I have the basic skills to make a
good businesswoman I just don't know
where to start or what I will be good at
yeah like a lot of lot of similar themes
I'm explore like take an internship at a
company and see if you like it see if
that's the life for you work part-time
for an entrepreneur and see if that's
what you want right entrepreneurship is
often glorified right like I want to be
like that person want to set my own
hours I want to do what I love but
there's a lot of downsides to it and you
know a lot of stress that you don't get
working in a big company so go work at
an entrepreneurs company that you admire
you want to be like and look at their
life like do you like their life are
they stressed out and pulling their hair
out and yelling all the time and hate it
or do they actually like their life and
do you want to be like that person or
Matt so just a whole bunch of little
text like if you're excited about
something you want to try it out don't
make it this big huge thing find a small
way to get started and see if you like
and if you like a little taste and go
taste some more right if you'd like that
dive full lane and see if you continue
to enjoy it and as soon as you stop
finding the passion for it move on to
something else right I think I mean I
can apply to what you're thinking about
to what are some key things you should
do when you start up to grow a brand or
YouTube channels fast as possible
missteps when you start up ah so for
starting a YouTube channel I think that
I mean the thing that's honestly helped
me the most is finding what i feel i
need in a youtube channel that's not out
there so i started my youtube channel
I think six years ago and got more
serious about it in the past two years
but it's taken me six years to get to
45,000 subscribers 40,000 subscribers
and in the past month we're going to add
15 thousand subscribers this is like
insane growth recently and that's a lot
to do with I felt like there was
something missing where I needed a
morning kick I needed a morning you know
shot of inspiration to start my day and
so he came up with the end special
series in the top 10 series I did it for
me like that wasn't anywhere out there
I'd be watching you know hour long video
of steve jobs in there like six Colonels
that you can take but you got to sit
through an hour to get there and I wish
somebody had made this condensed video
that I could watch and get all the gold
out of but nobody had done that so
that's what I did and that's what's
helped really propel my channel forward
so I've been looking at now what do you
wish was in the community that you're in
so like Brandon making clash of clans
videos what's missing like what do you
wish was out there that you could watch
you know maybe there wasn't moved there
isn't a coach who is teaching people how
to get better and asking their questions
one on one maybe there's something else
what's really missing for you and then
go create it so the stuff that I've made
on my channel is very selfish I did it
for me and I'm glad that other people
share in their love for what I'm doing
because I would will probably do it
anyway because I I love it what's the
maximum amount of money you should
invest into a part time business I hate
investing money into a business until I
make you money zero don't spend any
money on the business until you're
making money they'll spend money on gear
don't spend money on business cards an
office or a car or anything do you're
making money invest your energy your
drive your hustle until you're making
some money that's all you need to start
and Evan I think as well what would you
say to people who are scared to take on
say if your passion is electronics right
and yeah you just scared of the other
big brands like Douw Microsoft any big
brand what can people
do so the first thing is figuring out
what your story is I think entrepreneurs
don't do a good job of this and telling
your store because that's that's how you
beat a big company is making it personal
what's what's the what's your Microsoft
like who has a strong association of
Microsoft and loves Microsoft story
right there beyond it's a big company
there's not a lot of brand loyalty and
so if you could tell your story better
why you're starting this why it's
important to you you're going to track
like-minded people and that's that's how
you stand out the fear is knowing that
you could do something better right like
by confidence in your product of your
service that it's better than what these
guys are doing you're not going to take
on Microsoft and everything that they're
doing right it's it's there a humongous
company and it's figuring out the one
thing that you want to try to be better
than them at if you're going to make a
better software product or a better xbox
or whatever like your pick one thing you
want to be better at and just knowing
that you can be better at it like are
you actually good enough to outperform
the Microsoft engineers um you know I go
up against big companies all the time
and I end up working with them they end
up hiring me to come help them big
companies like Google and Microsoft and
Dell because they need my help because
they're not they don't know what they're
doing on some things they want my
assistance and I guess at the start you
know the first client that I work with I
was nervous it was a big telecom company
and I thought well white why are they
like they're a huge company why do they
need me right and then realize after
talking to them like wow these guys
really need me like you don't know what
they're doing and then in any company
that walk into its just me like if I
walk into a big company they have their
team of people executives and social
media people and interns and this whole
team and I'm walk
engines me but I know I can help them
you know and it's just having that
confidence in in your product or service
that where we going up against you know
that your product will be good if it's
not good then that's a then you don't
have anything to stand on but that's how
you have that's how you overcome the
fear is knowing that you can actually
help customers in a better way than the
big companies right should you trademark
an idea before starting the company you
can patent it maybe it's worth talking
to a patent lawyer about it but also
super expensive and really the patents
patents are more for investing the
natural operating the company um so
thinking about if you're going to need
investment to grow or not but otherwise
you don't trademark an idea and then how
do I not how do I not hold myself back I
think I'll help myself back with my
thoughts what's your advice on this yeah
so this is a huge issue like one of
motivation in limiting beliefs and I
believe that and friends may help you to
on one side you have your wants right
it's like that here's what i want to do
here's the career I want to start of the
business that I want to get involved in
and you can work on raising that up you
can work on like I want it more I want
it more here all the reasons why I want
it but if you're not following through
on it often it's because you're focusing
too much on the one side and not the
other side and on the other side you
have your fears you have your limiting
beliefs and you have your environment
and the fear is uh you know I don't
think I'm going to be successful I don't
think I'm gonna be good at this you're
limiting beliefs are you know I'm I'm
young so I can't be successful that was
well that's what I told myself and I was
19 I'm young I'm calling on these guys
who are you know in their 60s and have
PhDs and this huge background and I
can't do that how am I gonna sell it
those guys and it was until i discovered
that like I've avoided talking to them I
did not want to talk them because I was
afraid it was a limiting belief that was
only in my head when I talked to one I
realized that all they cared about is
can I help them if I could help them
they're happy to talk to a 19 year old
kid right and
I think more and more people are
recognizing that young people have
talents and skills that they don't have
right right terms of technology and
social media and there's a lot of skills
that young people have the older people
don't just from how we grew up I'm kind
of in between right I'm 35 so I'm not
I'm not old yet I hope but I'm not super
young either but I face that when i was
19 trying to sell software and i just
realized that when they understood that
i could help them they didn't care how
old i was what my background was you
just want to know how can I help them
but that helped me back so we all have
these limiting beliefs we tell ourselves
I don't have money so I can't do this
you know I'm an immigrant so I can't do
this I don't have education so I can't
do this like that's all in your head and
these limiting beliefs hold you back and
then it's your environment the people in
your life your friends your family the
books that you read the media that you
consume the TV shows that you watch the
video games that you play all of that
stopped the environment that you have
holds you where you are where if you
want to do something great you need to
have a great environment right and so
you want to surround yourself with
people ideas and resources that help you
become a much better version of yourself
and you know so you can't change your
parents obviously but you can change
your friends you can change where you
spend your time instead of watching you
know Game of Thrones streaming it on
online you can watch inspirational
videos from steve jobs and get his
advice right like where you spend your
time and who you surround yourself with
I surround myself with steve jobs and
Donald Trump and Richard Branson and AP
Giannini and and people who have never
met in my life and some of them are dead
but they inspire me they're part of my
network that make me want to do much
bigger things Wow and now that like that
most of the people in my life wow you've
done so much like congratulations you're
such a big success I'm like I've done
nothing like the mark that I want to
have on the world this is nothing this
is peanuts and most people can't
understand that because they're thinking
too small so I need to surround myself
with people who are thinking
way way bigger otherwise all all average
down to be at their level you know my
friends level and you want to avoid that
you don't want to be the best in your
circle you want to be the worst and have
that ambition to continue to grow so you
know back to the question what's holding
you back it's those things right it's
your fears you feel like you're not good
enough you feel like you don't have
whatever knowledge resources abilities
to do it it's your limiting beliefs the
story that you're telling yourself ye
can't be successful we're really it's
just a store in your head and and3 your
environment probably sucks like look at
look at your look at your physical
environment right look at your friends
your family your routine your schedule
it it contributes to you staying where
you are instead of you going on and
doing something great so we change that
combined with having the want then
you're much more likely to be successful
I think another question Evan as well as
and someone like Richard Branson yeah
what would you say I mean I've read his
book personally I'm sure you have to
yeah what would you say his passion was
you know for all of these successful
companies with the Virgin brand how has
he done that what was his passion to do
all of that that's a good question i'm
trying to think back to the early days
of Branson um the inter thing about him
is he's dyslexic right like he has all
these things he can't he can't read
things properly um he doesn't he doesn't
he went into meetings not knowing basics
of financial statements so a lot of
things that you would expect people to
know that that he doesn't know he just
you just broke the mold is like well I'm
not gonna let that hold me back like I'm
Dyslexic so I can still build a business
right um his first business I'm trying
to member was a with a was a newspaper I
think our magazine student magazine yeah
that's right and then he got into music
and then it's built up from there I
think his honestly I think his big
passion is taking on the establishment
he likes to get into industries and just
tear
up he likes going after big companies
that are in tired industries with the no
innovation and do something different
and he loves taking on challenges right
even in like you look what he does
personally trying to set records you
know try to balloon rides and the boats
and you know at site sometimes at a
serious personal risk to his own health
I think that's what really motivates him
he likes taking on just big huge
challenges and joined the world that
they can be done a different way and
he's a great entrepreneur follow because
he's done so many things with so many
setbacks that people would say there's
no way you could have done it um you
know he's we did a video on him I'll be
done the video we've done one I'm
working on the top 10 he's hard because
he's actually a terrible speaker if you
listen to a like a full hour of Richard
Branson it's really really hard to get
he's not he's not super succinct he's
not really clear he stutters a lot in
the stuff that he says um and yet he's a
megastar entrepreneur right well you
don't have to be fantastic on camera um
but he's honed in on what he's really
good at he likes making a big production
of things he likes you know riding the
tank through the streets of New York he
likes going after World Records and so
he looks to partner up like I don't know
how many virgin companies there are tons
but he looks basically form alliances
with people who wanted rock and change
traditional industries that's what is
really good at that's great like you've
discovered that he just goes all in on
it ah when you started out did you help
many people for free so you can gain
some contacts and they may help me in
the future um yeah and i still help
people for free right like what are we
doing right there and is not paying me
here right you guys aren't paying me
this is all for free uh what I think
what you'll find is as you get more
awareness people will start to talk
about you right so it's okay to start
for free
if you're good and people will come back
right and then they'll tell their
friends and they'll want to do it and
there'll be a crunch on your time so
when I started working with brands you
know the first deal i had was for five
hundred dollars not a lot of money i was
like five hundred dollars really it's
awesome and then i started increasing
the price because i had a limited amount
of time right it involved my newsletter
and i only do one newsletter a week's
only at four spots a month so as their
became more interest i started
increasing my price and you'll find that
as well with whatever business you're in
you start off you're building a name for
yourself you're building reputation
you're also getting better right like
you know if brendan starts doing clash
of Clan coaching he'll be okay at it the
start but then as he does more he'll get
better right as you get this not just in
the game but also in how to talk to
people and coach them and how to let
them see results with practice you get
better at anything um if you'd enough so
start getting people wanting to come
back they want to do more they'll start
offering to pay him their offer to pay
him more you know you only has so many
hours in a day so then he'll start the
increases prices and it you know money
comes from providing value so remember
why you can give somebody the more money
you're going to make that's like the
easiest rule in business if you're
providing somebody crazy value you're
going to get lots of money and so the
trick is to gain the experience to
provide the value because you could want
to start a business and want to provide
value but if you don't know what you're
doing you can't provide a lot of value
so you're not going to get a lot of
money that's why if you go work for a
company that you really want to learn
from or you know start your business on
the side get some practice get some
experience you set up not be able to
charge much the honest harsh truth is
because you're not actually providing
tons of value to somebody right my
videos have taken off recently because
they've gotten better and they provided
more value to people and people want to
share it and consume it and post it
everywhere so it's got a lot of great
results from that and so the same thing
with whatever you're trying to do figure
where the questions things are like
scrolling like crazy here I started off
by making it free i did the ymca thing
for free now it's ten thousand dollars
plus travel to get me to go speak in an
event right
I mean that that didn't just happen
overnight but as I got better at
speaking like my first presentation was
nowhere close to what it is now so I
start charging more the demand grows my
supply shrinks price is gonna go up
right at some point we got to cut this
off and all we've been talking for a
long time the questions are insane why
don't we leave it there I doesn't
branded you have you have you have a
last question here you want to go over
um I think we've really covered it I
mean I think that's what I want to do is
go out and you know explore different
ventures and just see where it leads me
really cool okay yeah I want to say
thank you for your videos by the way
Evan you know I've watched them for I
think just over a year now I love what
you do and I think you know one day this
will well I mean it already is a success
really you know you're helping a lot of
people out doing this and I just want to
say thanks cool man well I appreciate
that I'm glad we had this time everybody
watching I know the question they've
just been piling in and we only answered
like a third of them or something I
apologize for that but if you leave a
question once the video goes live on the
channel I'll see if I can make a video
response um and that's it love you guys
Thank You Brandon and dad will talk to
you soon believe she did thank you yes
all right and if you're doing league of
legends add me yeah I'm on the North
American server though so leave your
league of legends name in the comments
and i'll add you all right Thank You
Evan so choose bye